Hi everyone. My name is Andrew Dumont
and I work on AI engineering at
Watershed, the sustainability air
platform.
At Watershed, I work on AI for building
product carbon footprints and in turn
measuring the emissions associated with
all the things that a company buys and
sells. Sustainability, the vertical that
Watershed is in, is one with a ton of
expert judgment calls spread throughout
it and this has made building and
deploying agents both exciting and
challenging.
In this talk, I'll go deep on one of the
tasks within sustainability that we
spend quite a bit of time working on and
share learnings from our work deploying
coding agents on that task and why do do
I doing so has required that we respect
the process.
So just to give a bit of context on
sustainability as a vertical, we need to
answer questions like what are the
emissions attributable to one bottle of
wine or which method should be used to
allocate the emissions to various
co-products when there are multiple
sellable co-products that come from the
same industrial process.
In these cases, there are many ways to
get the right answer the wrong way and
there are also many right answers that
experts will disagree on.
And so, you have to verify the process
in addition to the answer because the
answer is really only justified in so
far as it the process that produced that
answer is correct.
One example of this comes from a study
in 2020 where six experts were given the
exact same data on the exact same bottle
of wine
and despite having all access to the
exact same things, they came to answers
that varied by up to 50%. Their expert
judgment were all correct in a sense,
but purely validating the answer here is
not sufficient to know that the answer
produced by a system trying to mimic
those experts is itself correct.
So with that context on sustainability
broadly and what kind of things that we
need to answer, let's zoom into a
specific task that we'll be talking
about for the remainder of the talk.
That task is to help users edit complex
graphs. Each of these graphs represents
the supply chain of a single product.
For example, on the right here, you can
see the graph represents dark wash
jeans.
Upstream of that is the assembly of that
jeans from the denim thread, labels, uh
and zipper, along with the energy,
transportation, and packaging that's
required to move uh move that through
the supply chain, and create uh and run
those industrial processes.
Each graph here represents the entire
flow of all of those things moving
through the supply chain, and is
comprised of thousands of nodes, each
with rich metadata describing the
materials and processing at each step.
And so, when we first tried to solve
this problem a little over a year ago,
it worked decently well on one graph. It
did have some problems, but we gave our
React agent highly specified tools for
exploring and interacting with the graph
via function calls.
And even while it worked, a few problems
were already apparent. Um it lacked
consistency where it could struggle to
explore sufficiently, and those tool
calls on a single graph took a lot of
context as it read deeply across these
nodes with lots of metadata.
But then, when we tried to scale it up
to many graphs, or frankly even just a
few graphs, it absolutely broke. The
lack of consistency was greatly
magnified with the agent taking one
approach in one graph, a different
approach in a second graph, and
completely forgetting about the third
graph, or even to handle it at all.
And exploration itself also became a
huge bottleneck because it took many
tool calls to explore and operate across
these graphs at scale.
And it also worsened the context problem
because these tool calls really gobbled
up context both on the edit side where
it actually needed to like make some
changes, and on the exploration side
where it needed to figure out what
changes to make. And worse, the agent
then really started to hallucinate
different parts of the schema as those
contexts got eaten, and despite those
specialized tools, this led to retries
and ultimately errors.
In data terms, the task now comprised
tens or hundreds of graphs, and tens to
hundreds of thousands of nodes that the
agent had to operate over.
So, time passed,
and coding agents got way better, and we
thought these will work great. So,
naturally, we swapped them in. And
swapping in a coding agent gave us like
three really important outcomes that we
were missing before. First, it gave the
agent the ability to delight users. The
agent could start to find clever ways to
solve these under-specified
and kind of not fully formed problems.
It could also create fancy
visualizations on the fly by writing
code to do that. And it could even
answer related questions because it had
kind of the full power of the coding
agent in this environment.
And what from our end we saw the agent
could explore and now edit way more
efficiently than before. It could write
loops over graphs and nodes. It could
write scripts to unpack and summarize
the node content underneath it all.
Basically, following the same pattern of
data exploration that goes on in kind of
agentic data science workflows.
And beyond that, it also gave it the
flexibility and power to do stuff
outside what we even designed it for,
which was really exciting. And we're to
this day consistently finding entirely
new use cases via new questions users
ask and new things that they want to try
with this agent.
We were really excited. We put it out
into the world. We started to write a
bunch of evals for it. And we quickly
learned that unconstrained code is quite
scary. If you're watching this, you've
probably had that experience with cloud
code where it's gone a bit haywire
towards achieving whatever goal you set
it out to do. It reached for something
you didn't think it could or should
reach for or even had access or found a
way to access something you didn't think
it could.
Um for us, this looks like the agent
will find creative ways to pretty much
solve any problem. In our case, we saw
it write Python when we expected
TypeScript and and instructed it to
write TypeScript because it found Python
on the virtual machine that we had given
it.
Or it would directly edit these graph
artifacts underlying the data without
leaving any lineage behind by just like
directly modifying um parameters or data
rather than actually like writing code
to effectively do that.
Second, the agent actually started to
gaslight users sometimes saying it had
made edits when it hadn't.
Um it would write code that did that it
thought was going to do make like have
the effect that it wanted to. And then
it said, "I'm done. Everything's
Everything's working. It's exactly what
you said." And the edits were not
actually made. And so it it kind of lied
to users or at least let them to believe
that the edits were done as they
expected it to be done.
And then lastly, once the agent had
completed its task, it was now much
harder to review its work. Um manual
review of code is not something that are
is in our users' wheelhouse. They are
not software engineers or may or may not
have had experience with code before.
And when the agent is right for the
wrong reasons, which happens uh or can
happen frequently in our in
sustainability broadly, it's really hard
to check its work without going and
reading that code directly.
And so this process is not the answer.
Story is really not new. Um a recent
paper uh in from 2026, the Open Proof
Corpus, showed that there can be quite a
big gap between the correct final answer
and and the correct proof. Though that
is, you know, potentially closing. But
And this is in math where there is like
a fully verifiable answer. And so this
We view this problem as even worse where
you can't fully verify the answer. And
this has been found in the agents what
reward hack um even as something as
complex as the Erdos problems, um you're
going to get many, many pages of of
errors in your proof which have which
lead nowhere um to impossible bench to
um other kind of areas in math where
this can where they can The authors of
this paper, Beyond Correctness, conclude
that this can pose significant risk for
critical applications. Now, all this is
not to say that we shouldn't use coding
agents. We don't want to constrain how
the agent reasons. We get so many
benefits from these powerful models, but
we also can't perfectly verify the
answer in our case. So we don't even
know when the final answer is definitely
correct. Uh because these expert
judgment calls are ever present our
space. So, the main lever left is
validating the process and making sure
that we are following it in a way we
expect. And to do that, we frame it as
constraining the effects, not the
expression.
So, our task begins with a user request.
And from this, the agent can then go off
and freely write code to execute on that
user request.
However, we require that all the
critical code, really the stuff that
edits the graph, goes through a filter
of this typed SDK that we've put
together where we can lint and check for
errors.
And then we own the final execution step
to guarantee that we create these typed
objects that we can commit as the actual
edits to the graph. And these are then
faithful to the process. And all of this
together
means that the entire process is valid,
traceable, and replayable. And if it's
not, we can reject and retry and send it
back to the agent to let it know that
something has gone awry.
So, let's go a little deeper on the
typed SDK and the deterministic
execution. So, first, our SDK is the
only door. What we give to the agent in
our case is a TypeScript SDK with all
the edit primitives the agent needs to
make changes to graphs, as well as
explore and interact with the kind of
graph objects.
This for us enforces which fields are
editable versus which are derived from
other fields, so the agent can't create
conflicts with itself where it edits
just the target thing that it cares
about, but not the thing that creates
that target thing. And it also
guarantees that it objects that we
expect it to so that we can actually
like make use of the outputs of this in
a deterministic way.
Now, of course, this does require
teaching the agent how to actually make
use of this SDK, but this is the same
kind of pattern that we see with
teaching an agent to like write code in
your code base where you tell it how it
works. You can, you know, do the prompt
and all of that kind of stuff. The agent
also has full access to the docs and the
code underlying the SDK if it really
needs to go and read that as well.
Just for a brief example on the right
here, you can see an example with a few
pieces of the SDK on display. We import
um from our API. We The agent has to
then define kind of a top-level edit
function with a well-defined name. It
then can use uh find nodes by exact name
to find specific nodes that it's looking
for in the graph. It can write
assertions that we give it to make sure
that um its code fails early um as well.
And then it can use uh specific mutator
functions like set rate and edit node to
actually interact with the graph in a
way that will produce those kind of
typed objects that we care about.
So, that's the SDK, but the actual
guarantee here is when we own the
deterministic execution. So, even with
the typed SDK as our entry point, that
really only guides the agent towards the
desired end state. And the real
guarantee comes from the final script
that we orchestrate on agent completion.
This run executor script um
it is called when the agent has kind of
completed running, and we think that
we're in a like almost completed state
or a ready to be completed state. And
what that script does is it starts by
linting the agent code, where we can
immediately send it back to the agent if
something is wrong. Better to kind of
fail early rather than fail later.
We can also detect conflicts. This is
where sometimes the agent in one part of
the code edited something in another
part edited the same thing or something
that depended on the first one and
didn't realize that that happened.
Because we have these guarantees, by
giving the agent this well-defined
structure, we can detect those conflicts
for it so that we can send it back to
the agent.
We then run the agent edited code, and
that means that we can then validate the
output artifacts. Of course, if the code
itself fails to run, we can send that
back to the agent, too.
And then finally, once we have the
validated output artifacts, we can
create a well-structured review artifact
that makes it easy to review what the
agent did without having to actually
ever go read the underlying code that
produced it. To give you a flavor of
what that looks like, here's a little
snippet from an emissions report where
the graph edit function impact analysis
ran on 50 graphs.
Um there were two functions that it
applied that produced 749 edit actions,
and it ultimately in this case reduced
the overall emissions by 45.6%
and we can even go to go to see there
are two code there are two edits here.
Um one kind of did a big chunk and the
other one made a very small change.
Maybe you'd go look at what this
actually did, and then you can even go
at a graph level and say, "Okay, for
this graph, like what was the option one
and which nodes did it edit within that
graph to get a sense of um what actually
happened under the hood?" So, you can
see all of this without actually having
to go read the low-level code.
So, to return to those three problems
that uh we started with, now that we
have these kind of two broad concepts
that are part of the harness, um
when the agent will find creative ways
to solve every problem, this is now a
great thing, but we've limited it a
little bit. These invalid actions that
the agent will take on its route to
solve whatever problem we presented are
actually prevented with the type dust
SDK as the only way to properly edit the
graph, and then we can guarantee that
the graph was only edited through the
SDK by owning the deterministic
execution and the validation of that
written code.
The second problem about the agent
saying that it made an edit when
actually that the edit didn't go through
in the way that it or the user expected,
these false reports are caught via that
deterministic execution so that we can
surface those back to the agent um to
make sure that it's doing what it
claimed.
And finally, our users never have to
look at the code because the
deterministic execution system produces
artifacts in an expected form, and we
can build verification against those to
catch both the kind of good outcomes and
the errors that are now surfaced clearly
to both the user um and the AI. So, even
when it hasn't maybe gotten exactly the
right answer or the one that the user
expected, it's easy to follow its logic
and kind of get to that um and loop back
on itself.
Now, the harness is all well and good as
it's kind of adds constraints, but I
also want to emphasize that even with
those great guarantees, you still need
to hill climb to get better at the task
itself. Since we started tracking how
well the agent did at these complex
edits, where each task here um in our
eval set is a collection of graphs and a
goal,
um we've been able to improve our
outcomes from about 43% to 92% on our
set of internal evals. And to achieve
that, all the typical approaches were
still effective. We did a ton of prompt
improvements, like rewriting the system
prompt and all the kind of skills that
the agent had access to. We've added few
shot examples to both teach and coach
the agent how to make use of the SDK and
work with these different classes of
tasks that we expect.
We also had to make the tools, the SDK
itself, and the tools the agent had
access to better fit for use by
improving their kind of ergonomics and
how obvious they were for the agent to
use. We also broke the task down through
doing this, breaking up the um overall
problem to a plan and execute kind of
standard loop, as well as teaching the
agent some of that expert judgment that
is endemic in our space, making that
easier for the agent to operate on it
and to
elicit that expert judgment from the
user. But the important thing here is
even though we've kind of improved the
accuracy here, which is amazing, and
it's great that we'll now kind of get
better at that first time a user goes
through the full workflow in the task,
um even when the agent errors, or even
our ground truth is, you know, one of
those points on the possible range of
expert judgments, we can still guarantee
and validate the um process itself.
So, to bring it all together in a domain
full of expert judgments, you must
respect the process, too. And for that,
you really need guarantees about the
process.
We all know coding agents are necessary
for complex tasks, and they will
continue to be necessary and extremely
useful. But those power that power comes
with many risks that are like good to go
and clear eyed about. For tasks with
complex data and judgment calls, we now
think that the harness should do a few
important things. First, it should give
the agent well scoped primitives to
interact with the kind of external
system that it's actually supposed to
work with. Um free freely operating code
can, you know, lead to a lot of the
things that we talked about earlier. And
this really allows the builders of the
system to allow and disallow specific
things and exercise the full power of
these coding agents while still trusting
the process that they're working in.
I think the harness should also maintain
full control of the final execution.
These very smart agents may declare
victory in an unexpected way from what
you or your user really want them to
declare. And so it's important to be
able to constrain and validate that the
agent has actually done what it said
it's done.
And finally, you should use that
deterministic final outcome to produce
outputs that are easy to validate even
for non-coders. The code is kind of just
the means to an end.
And then of course, the kind of standard
context and prompt engineering will of
course remain critical to better scoping
and defining that task and making it
clear what the agent needs to do.
That's it for me. Again, I'm Andrew
Dumit at Watershed, the sustainability
AI platform. Thank you again for your
time and attention.